herzlich willkommen
ja der lockdown der retter zu erleben
aber er kostet auch angeblich drei bis
fünf milliarden schweizer franken pro
monat
was bedeutet diese verschuldung für die
kommenden jahre kommt die große konkurs
welle die globale rezession die
inflation und welche wirtschaft brauchen
wir für die zukunft darüber rede ich
jetzt mit monika bütler sie ist
wirtschaftsprofessor an der universität
st gallen mitglied der kogit 19 task
force des bundesrates und sie gilt als
wichtigste ökonom in der schweiz
herzlich willkommen frau witte 3 bis 5
milliarden schweizer franken pro monat
das ist ganz schön viel geld nicht das
ist viel geld ja das ist eine norden
große zahl die wir so einig und
wirtschaft einbrüche nicht kennen so
lange zeit ein teil dieser drei bis fünf
millionen milliarden kommt von den
massnahmen ob die krankheit selber
verursacht eben auch kosten und darum
ist es so schwierig auch diese drei bis
fünf milliarden wirklich einzuschätzen
wir wissen ja nicht was passiert wäre
wenn wir die maßnahme nicht gehabt
hätten möglicherweise werden die schäden
blieben noch größer gibst als szenarien
wie man ökonomisch durchgerechnet hat ja
man hat natürlich versucht szenarien
durchzurechnen das ist immer sehr
schwierig weil es gibt ja fast keine
leinburger keine länder die wirklich
nichts gemacht haben also wir uns fehlen
irgendwie die hinweise auch ob wir
wissen in der zwischenzeit das doch ein
großer teil des einbruchs von verhaltens
anpassungen der leute kommen
die gehen nicht mehr ins kino sie
bleiben zu hause selbst wenn sie nicht
müssen sie versuchen kontakte
einzuschränken
man hat vor dem ersten lok dann gesehen
dass etwa die hälfte des einbruches bis
zu zwei dritteln eben von verhaltens
anpassungen gekommen sind und nicht von
den eigentlichen maßnahmen
zwei drittel bis zu 232 drittel einfach
weil die leute weniger konsumieren
weniger raus gehen nicht mehr ins
restaurant gehen dass ich anders
verhalten beispielsweise bei den
restaurants sich der einbruch in der
schweiz ab dem ersten märz beobacht war
den lockt am 16 märz bei den usa selbst
in staaten wo keine oder wenig
einschränkungen waren war das genau war
ich etwa zwei wochen vorher das ist die
große unsicherheit die angst vor der
krankheit man weiß nicht die jungen
gehen und dann geht man auf nummer
sicher niemand wie sich freiwillig und
stecken
das zeigt schon wie viel ökonomie
wirtschaft mit psychologie zu tun hat
mit vertrauen mit optimierten für mich
als ökonomischer ist natürlich
interessant wenn ich solche zahlen
höhere drei bis fünf milliarden pro
monat
da frage ich mich woher nehmen wir
eigentlich dieses geld oder bei wem
haben wir diese schulden ja das ist eine
gute frage
die schweiz hat in den letzten zehn 15
jahren ziemlich viel gespart dass die
staatsschulden wurden zurückgefahren und
was wir haben ja über 100 milliarden
schulden haben auch im internationalen
vergleich ist die schweiz eines der am
wenigsten verschuldeten länder und wir
konnten die staatsverschuldung doch
deutlich reduzieren
einer der gründe weshalb man die
staatsverschuldung zurückgefahren hat
war auch ja wir brauchen reserven für
die zukunft wir brauchen reserven für
eine austritt excel schaffte brauchen
aber reserven für wenn es wirklich mal
schlecht geht und jetzt geht es uns
schlecht
und darum ist es auch sinnvoll jetzt
diese sozusagen angesparten gelder oder
das was man wirklich nicht ausgegeben
hat denjenigen betrieben denjenigen
leuten zukommen zu lassen dass auch
wirklich nötig haben
aber noch mal woher haben wir dieses
geld bei wem machen wir diese schulden
bei uns selber vor allem also das ist ja
eigentlich sind sind schulden sind
ausgaben die wir später über die steuern
irgendwie oder weniger staatsausgaben
wieder zurückzahlen
man hat bei niemandem schulden nicht bei
anderen staaten also man druckt einfach
geld und nein
eine gute frage natürlich hat man die
schulden die sind irgendwo diese in
beiden pensionskassen die sind bei den
bürgern die sparen die sind in vielen
ländern auch im ausland auch in der
schweiz zum teil
die sind natürlich irgendwo das sind
leute die sparen der staat gibt geld aus
oder verschuldet sich die titel aus die
die leute die sparen wollen kaufen diese
titel staatsschulden neben voran
pensionskassen banken aber auch
individuen um die später daneben
verkaufen zu können
ok also man hat kauft schuld man handelt
dann mit diesen schuldpapieren ja es
braucht natürlich bekam nicht schulden
machen ohne dass es eine gegenseite gibt
die die schulden nach kaufte momentan
ist es so dass er mehr leute
staatsschulden kaufen möchten aus
überhaupt staatsschulden weil die
renditen auf den bankkonten tief war
negativ
sogar auf den straßen sehen sie negativ
muss man auch sagen da müssen natürlich
sichere titel wenn ich sicher sein will
mit sparen da kauf ich vielleicht lieber
eine staatsschuld sozusagen als dass ich
etwas anderes gab und gibt es wie so
eine kritische obergrenze von schulden
die ein staat machen kann oder kann man
jetzt warum hat man nicht gesagt man
kann nach 200 milliarden schulden haben
sie kein problem
jetzt ist eine frage die ökonomen schon
sehr lange umgetrieben hat was ist
sozusagen eine optimale verschuldung
eine maximale verschuldung daraus sind
die auch die kriterien der in der eu
entstanden dieser maastricht-kriterien
sagen
aus der erfahrung weiß man etwa 60 mit
60 prozent der jährlichen wertschöpfung
eines landes ist so eine eine richtgröße
die dann auch eingang gefunden hat
es gibt aber auch untersuchen sie sagen
ist auch 100 prozent des
bruttoinlandprodukts jährlichen
wertschöpfung ist noch tragbar
die schweiz hat deutlich weniger
deutlich unter 40 prozent
wir sind wirklich eines der am wenigsten
verschiedensten ländern und trotzdem
machen wir jetzt wieder weiter schulden
oder wie jetzt sozusagen nehmen aus
diesem angesparten von diesen 15 jahren
das brauchen wir jetzt die frage ist
werden ihre kinder meine kinder diese
krise bezahlen müssen werden die noch
spüren also in was ich 20 30 jahren
ja wir werden alle diese krise bezahlen
muss und die frage ist wie wenn diese
staatsschulden werden jetzt gebraucht um
betriebe zu entschädigen die geschlossen
sind um die die arbeitslosen
versicherung zu finanzieren
die frage ist was passiert wäre wenn wir
das nicht gemacht hätten wir keine
einschränkung gehabt hätte dann wäre mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit während die
verwerfungen der wirtschaft mindestens
so groß wenn ich größer gewesen und dann
hätten wir das geld auch ausgegeben in
form von weniger steuereinnahmen weniger
produktionen arbeitslosigkeit in der
zukunft also man kann nicht einfach
sagen dass wir jetzt ausgeben und die
christ bewältigen ist verlorenes geld
das hätten wir nicht ausgegeben wenn wir
das nicht gemacht hätten
das hat ja auch gekostet also ich habe
meinen studierenden kürzlich gesagt ja
wir bezahlen das so oder so und die
jüngeren mehr als wir
ich muss aber auch sagen die die die
konditionen also quasi der preis der
stadt der verschuldung momentan ist sehr
tief also die staatsschulden die werft
der sogar momentan noch rendite ab die
die zehn sie ist auch total unter null
das heißt noch lange nicht dass die
schulden gratis sind aber es ist
mindestens um zeitpunkt jetzt wo sich
eine eine maßvolle verschuldung wirklich
lohne um die die die schäden an der
wirtschaft abzufedern
es ist ja interessant also die
konjunkturforschungsstelle der eth oder
auch die weltbank die rechnet für dieses
jahr mit einem ungefähr dreiprozentigen
wirtschaftswachstum
und zu beginn der krise im april 2020
hat die der internationale währungsfonds
noch gesagt diese pandemie werde
gravierende folgen haben und die chefin
hat gesagt es kann mit zur schwersten
globalen rezession seit fast 100 jahren
war das eine totale fehleinschätzung
oder kann das nochmals nein nein das ist
natürlich keine fehleinschätzung 100
jahre ist vielleicht etwas übertrieben
nicht die welt
krisen den 30er jahren war
wahrscheinlich deutlich tiefer bei 29
jahr genauso werden aber es ist eine
eine ganz gravierende krise und man darf
sich von diesem 3,5 prozent dieses jahr
natürlich nicht blenden lassen mein
letztes jahr acht prozent zurückgehen
beispielsweise in vielen europäischen
ländern
dann ist 3 prozent ist immer noch zu
wenig und dort zu landen wo wir 2009 10
aufgehört haben
also je tiefer das sieht man auch bei
dem vergleich der europäischen länder
stärker der einbruch war letztes jahr
desto größer wird auch das wachstum
wieder seien in diesem oder im nächsten
jahr war das immer im vergleich zum
vorjahr sei das eben vergleichbar ist
insofern natürlich diese zahl 3 prozent
ja das täuscht und am schluss ich finde
es immer ein bisschen unschön oder ein
bisschen man man sieht die krise weniger
rennen einfach dass die jahre stöckelt
wie viel uns gekostet hat das werden wir
ende jahr anfangs nächstes jahr
vielleicht sehen und man spürt so schön
sie sind eigentlich für die
unterstützung der der leidtragenden in
dieser krise und das haben wir alle
erlebt wir haben in dieser krise eine
stärkung des staates erlebt zuerst
natürlich mit den einschränkungen mit
den verboten mit den maßnahmen aber auch
jetzt mit der finanziellen unterstützung
also es gibt die kredite dann die
kurzarbeitsentschädigung die härtefall
hilfen für sie als liberale ökonomen wie
passt das eigentlich zusammen dieses
starke eingreifen des staates positiv
wie negativ verbot der unterstützung zu
einem liberalen freiheitsverständnis und
einem gesellschaftsverständnis und
wirtschafts verstehen
das ist eine gute frage aber der staat
habt ihr gewisse aufgaben die auch die
austro liberalen nie bestreiten würden
beispielsweise eben beide beim ausgleich
von risiken die nicht versichert werden
können oder aber bei wenn sie beim
freiheitsbegriff sind die freiheit hört
natürlich dort dafür mich wo sie die
freiheit
der anden einschränkt und das ist
momentan natürlich eine ganz ganz
schwierige frage wo die freiheiten
aufhören weil gerade in einer pandemie
sind die sogenannten nächsten qualitäten
also die die effekte die ich nur dich
durch mein tun verursachen
beispielsweise wenn ich an gestreckt
rumlaufe die die kann ich ja die
berücksichtigt selber nicht das kann nun
anstatt also nur gestört kann sozusagen
dort eingreifen wo eben die
freiheitsrechte der einen die
freiheitsrechte den anderen gefährten
also freiheit als wir sie immer gleiche
freiheit für alle
und da wo ich mir mehr freiheit nehme
und die anderen einschränkt jetzt in
diesem fall auch hinter gesundheit also
wenn ich hab mich nicht an die maßnahmen
hatte dann werde ich andere person also
sie haben das genau gesagt ist es gibt
da keine irgendwie fixe grenze das ist
bei uns schwierigen beispielsweise die
älteren leute den heimen wohnen die
können ja gar nichts mehr machen die
können sich eigentlich fast nicht selber
verteidigen und wo schützen wir jetzt
wie stark schützen wir die leute die
sehr wohl aber sind das ist es letztlich
ein auch und wertet eine wertediskussion
und nicht nur eines sicher keine
ökonomische diskussion aber der staat
ist genau diese diese fragen eben im
diskurs auch mit den leuten zu
beantworten
wir halten uns alle an verkehrsregeln
deshalb weil es für alle besser ist wenn
wir unseren verkehrsregeln halten
bei der pandemie ist ein bisschen
schwieriger natürlich meine ich nicht
einfach sagen kann jetzt gehen alle
rechts und links es ist viel viel
kompliziertere mich da können wir
einschränken wird auch gewogen wir
einschränken wie stark holen die die
einzel gerade die jungen einschränken um
die verletzliche neben zu schützen das
ist keine einfache frage haben sich gab
das ist auch die große schwierigkeit der
politik momentan dann mit dem zweiten
rolle des staates sozusagen als
rückversicherer
das ist auch eine wichtige rolle da
staunt dass wir können viele richtigen
können ja selber versichern wir können
uns gegen
brand des hauses für sich haben
autoversicherung sogar
krankenversicherung das ist wahr
reguliert aber das ist eine private
versicherung ab die großen
makroökonomischen risiken und
versicherer der stadt was wären was aus
also einer pandemie sollen sich auch die
finanzkrise war eine große
makroökonomische krise dann wenn man
weiter zurückgeht die ölpreiskrise in
den 70er jahren an rekord von krise
kriegen herkommen aber gerade bei der
finanzkrise also da wurden ja die großen
banken dann angeblich weil sie too big
to fail waren gerettet
da hätte man aber sagen kann 'die werden
acht teils schuldig gewesen und heute
ist es ja in der pandemie so dass wir
das unklar ist wer eigentlich schuld ist
an dieser katastrophe ist und sich
selbst bei der finanzkrise nicht grund
so einfach zu sehen will ist da schon ob
sie haben schon recht die die herkunft
es ist viel stärkeren sogenannter
exogene schocks sei ein schock da
wirklich von außen her kommt mit dem bon
jovi als es doch bei der finanzkrise war
wo halt gerade die den finanzsektor
irgendwo halt auch mit schulden ich das
schuldig nicht mit beteiligt war
und natürlich auch durch aus rationalen
gründen diese entwicklungen mitgemacht
habt das habt ihr wirklich nicht also
niemand selbst selbst die klubs die
vielleicht zu den zu den breites gehören
gehört haben die tragen keine schuld
niemand trägt die schuld und diese
pandemie und deshalb ist es wirklich für
den staat halt hatte stark eine wichtige
rolle hier aus versicherer zu wirken ist
das auch eine lektion also dass die
verlierer einer so eine krise großzügig
entschädigt werden sollen dass der staat
auch in so einem moment irgendwie das
ersparte neben soll oder sogar schulden
machen so ist es eine lehre eine lektion
die man aus der ökonomie vielleicht
gelernt hat von einem der größten
ökonomen des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
dem britischen ökonomen john maynard
keynes der genau das gesagt hat nämlich
in der krise braucht einen starken staat
der muss schulden machen muss die zinsen
senken muss investitionsprogramme
lancieren um die arbeitslosigkeit
zu vermeiden war prägend dann in der
nach jahren der wirtschaftskrise
natürlich ist das ein modell hat dass
man zurück greift heute oder hat das
sozusagen die als richtschnur ist ja gar
nicht mehrmals gehört ja ich bin nicht
unbedingt jemand wer das wohl der ideen
geschichtlich so viel her leidet aber es
ist natürlich ganz so wie sie wie sie
richtig sagen kann sollte eine extrem
wichtige rolle gerade in der
weltwirtschaftskrise und seine rezepte
haben sich nachher über jahre eigentlich
waren die die wurden die angewandt von
den staaten bis in die 70er jahre und
die idee dahinter ist dass der staat vor
allem verwerfungen die von der nachfrage
her kommt dass die leute aus
irgendwelchen gründen kaufen zu wenig
bezahlen sich zu wenige güter werden
nicht nachgefragt dass der staat geraten
diesen rezessionen eben helfen können
programme lanciert bauprogramme
beispielsweise infrastrukturprogramm in
denen die geldpolitik sehr locker ist
um diese nachfrage wieder und kurven
künstlicher auch ein bisschen vielleicht
auch mit nicht nicht unbedingt sinnvoll
projekten manchmal ab sache die leute
können arbeiten kann man so zu spät das
ist das typische beispiel ist man
kräftigen graben unter den wieder zu die
idee dahinter ist dass das in einer
rezession unter umständen besser ist
auch zu tun als gar nichts
das hat sich in der zwischenzeit schon
ein bisschen überholt dass wir versuchen
anders auf solche krisen zu reagieren
aber es ist tatsächlich immer noch so
dass bei rezession daneben wo die
nachfrage sozusagen fehlt und die leute
weniger arbeit haben dadurch weniger
konsumieren dadurch vielleicht ein
wirtschaftsabschwung noch stärken dass
der staat eine wichtige rolle hat heute
geschieht das natürlich vor allem über
die so genannten automatischen
stabilisatoren das heißt
arbeitslosenversicherung die geben
automatisch mehr
wenn es uns schlecht geht da braucht es
keine entscheidung jetzt treffen über
die steuereinnahmen die automatisch
kleiner werden wenn es uns schlechter
geht auch der stadt nichts zu machen und
die steuereinnahmen sollten auch wieder
höher sein wenn die krise vorbei ist
das heißt die ansichten von cain sind
sozusagen die systeme eingewandert und
abends stabilisierende wirkung ja mein
ich glaube dass sich frauen heute die
meisten ökonomen würden heute sagen es
ist in erster linie an die datenlage wir
wissen ja viel mehr stört die zeiten von
keynes die hatten kam daten zum
wirtschaftsgeschehen die das
bruttoinlandprodukt eben die jährliche
werkstatt von wurde vielleicht im
halbjahresrhythmus wenn es wirklich gut
kommt im vierjahresrhythmus gemessen
ganz schlecht
man hatte zahlen zur arbeitslosen aber
auch ganz schlecht und durch die durch
die entwicklung der datenlage der
letzten 20 30 oder 50 jahre hat es dazu
geführt dass wir uns natürlich auf band
andere grundlagen stützen und nicht nur
nach ideen sondern eben weg ich habe da
es gibt in sachen ideen gibt es ja noch
einen gegenspieler nach der dann vor
allem in den 80er jahren als berater von
ronald reagan und margaret thatcher
wegweisend war nämlich milton friedman
der us amerikanische ökonom vertreter
der chicago school of economics und er
plädiert er für einen zurückhaltenden
start und auch in dem er auf die gefahr
der inflation hinweis in dem auf der
staat geld im system vielleicht mögen
sie danach kurz erläutern wie wichtig
der waren oder wie steht er ja
vielleicht ich zehn jahre zurückgehen
dann in die 70er jahren der ölpreiskrise
hat sich dann gezeigt dass das modell
von keynes dass man durch temporär
höhere inflation die arbeitslosigkeit
senken kann also inflation entsteht
indem man mir kein thema mehr geld in
den wirtschaftskreislauf pumpt dass man
durch eine eine akzeptanz von einer
pizzen höheren inflation temporär eben
die arbeitslosigkeit senken kann
und in der ölpreiskrise ist deutlich
passiert das soll
inflation gestiegen ist als auch die
arbeitslosigkeit und die ölpreiskrise
ist eigentlich ein klassisches beispiel
von dem was dann mit frieden dazu
veranlasst hat die ganze kenyanische
ansichten bisschen in frage zu stellen
dass nämlich dass der schock nicht von
der nachfrage von den leuten aus kam von
firmen zu hunderten von vom ölpreis und
sogenannter angebotsschock war und diese
angebotsschock steve und
produktionsunterbrechung jetzt auch
während der krise oder eben von
ölpreisschocks hier kommen die lassen
sich mit den methoden von kanes nicht
nicht einfach so beheben was wenn die
güter plötzlich nicht mehr draußen oder
viel zu teuer wenn sie viel zu teuer
sind
dann ist die der umwelt geben über die
geldpresse und starke die kenyanische
nachfrage besteht aus führenden
tatsächlich zu höherer inflation
das ist die die gleichung eben mehr geld
führt letztlich auch zu mehr inflation
eins zu eins und wie ihr sitzt die
gefahr nach dieser krise dass es zu
einer inflation kommt ja die gefragte
kriseninformation die steht ja schon
lange im raum
wir haben eine wahnsinnige ausdehnung
der geldmenge geht alle notenbanken der
welt also insbesondere auch in der
schweiz den usa die geldmenge ist raum
ausgedehnt und wenn sozusagen diese
geldmenge nicht zurückgenommen werden
kann später mal dann führt das zur
information
die frage ist schaffen wir das geben die
die geldmenge wirklich so schaffen wir
das schaffen die nationalbanken dass die
geldmenge so zu regulieren dass das land
letztlich in die inflation nicht
entsteht und das zweite ist ob der
patient steht wie sie wie sie wie
schnell sie geht und ich glaube da die
prognosen gehen da extrem auseinander
und ich habe zu meinem mann schon zwei
mal gewettet und zwar 0 gewonnen er hat
die frühere inflation prognostiziert
wir sind wissen schlecht diversifiziert
naja immerhin ich genau diese
stossrichtung
sie sind ja man spürt das schon sie
haben das angetönt nicht so sehr auf die
alten herren der ökonomie der geschichte
fokussiert sondern auf daten auf studien
sehr empirisch sehr pragmatisch habe ich
auch den eindruck aus forscherin
sie haben physik und mathematik studiert
da zeigt sich schon sozusagen die
affinität zu den zahlen für sie als
ökonomin was haben sie dazu gelernt das
war die wichtigste lektion in dieser
krise in sachen
wirtschaftswissenschaften für sie ja das
ist eine gute frage
ganz viel ich glaube dass wir zuerst
gelernt haben wir haben seit nötig seit
vielen jahrzehnten niemals und job
gehabt der sich auf allen seiten alles
beeinflusst haben wir haben vorher funk
1 gerettet das sind nachfrageschock sie
die leute kaufen zu wenig oder im haben
zu wenig geld weil sie arbeitslos sind
dann die nach die angebots schocks von
friedman das mit dem ölpreisschock hier
sind die lieferketten plötzlich
unterbrochen worden aus china zuerst in
den anderen ländern dann auch in europa
über italien
gleichzeitig hat mir eine riesige
gesundheitskrise und alles zusammen zu
verstehen hat schon ziemlich viel
energie gebrauchten eben auch daten was
mich persönlich überrascht hat ist
ich bin ich immer davon ausgegangen dass
sich die wirtschaft relativ schnell
anpassen kann
das sagt man bei immer wieder gesehen
aber wie schnell sich gewisse prozess
eben verändert haben während des
lockouts nachher auch während im sommer
ist schon ziemlich eindrücklich im seien
viele betriebe umgestellt ganz ganz
schnell
es hat viele betriebsgründung gegeben
ich viel mehr als wir uns zitiert haben
die die menschen haben sich auch relativ
schnell angepasst ich habe diese diese
schnelligkeit der anpassung hat mich
persönlich überrascht
also sie denken jetzt auch an so etwas
wie home office also die ganzen
arbeitsprozess in die ganze arbeitswelt
die ganze arbeitswelt ja die auch die
produktionen es hat natürlich zum teil
auch die gewisse entwicklungen die schon
da waren einfach beschleunigt
beispielsweise dass viele lieferketten
wieder zurückgenommen werden nach europa
weil er vieles automatisiert werden kann
dann braucht es nicht mehr eine
auslagerung nach asien beispielsweise
und die genau diese neuorganisation der
lieferketten die schon angefangen hat
vor der pandemie ist sicher beschleunigt
wurde also würden sie sagen diese
automatisierung hat auch mit
digitalisierung zu tun das führt dazu
dass die globalisierung sich ein
bisschen zurück nimmt dass man hier
wieder ins lokal zurück kann nicht so
sehr die pandemie die irgendwie auch da
war die globalisierung natürlich auch
ein brandbeschleuniger kann man sagen
oder in einer globalisierten welt
verbreiten sich wären natürlich
schneller aber es ist eher die
digitalisierung die das noch vorantreibt
es ist die digitale hinweis darauf neue
produktionsmöglichkeiten also die roma
die sicherung ist nicht nur die
digitalisierung sondern auch die
regierung dass das das gewisse eben
lieferketten wieder verändert gibt mit
der globalisierung ist es uns wichtig
erschwert natürlich die verbreitung des
virus ist durch diese extreme mobilität
der menschen konnte gar nicht
eingeschränkt werden und wir hatten dann
auch sehr unschöne szenen im
februar/märz sich länder anfing
abzuschotten
dann aber gab es dann relativ schnell
eine entwicklung auch zurück wo man
gemerkt hat die globalisierung heißt
eben nicht nur schlechtes sodann dass
die die gegenseitige versicherung der
länder hat wieder angefangen zu spielen
es kommt kein einziges land kann sich
heute alleine versorgen als grund ist
noch nie aber dass das letztlich in der
zeit wo italien extrem stark getroffen
wurden haben andere länder ein also
helfen können
das wäre auch nicht möglich gewesen mit
abgeschotteten leyen mit mit
abgeschotteten grenzen
also die letztlich kann man nicht die
globalisierung verantwortlich machen das
ist die pandemie so gegeben hat man die
spanische grippe war 19 18 19 19
der alkohol ist hier noch viel weniger
stark die verbreiterung der ist gericht
bei wir uns war weniger schnellen aber
sie war auch um die ganze welt
sie würden sagen das so zu sagen jetzt
dass auch keine lektion sein soll
die lieferketten kürzer zu machen
sondern er sich besser abzusichern mehr
zu diversifizieren also mehrere
sozusagen lieferoptionen sich offen zu
ich hätte sagen viele firmen gemacht
die meisten firmen die das nicht schon
vorher gemacht haben
die waren nicht an diese lieferketten
wirklich stärker zu diversifizieren
das hat natürlich zum teil schon früher
begonnen
gerade mit gewissen handels ein paar
gegen gegen china beispielsweise oder
die usa dass die firma nach gezwungen
waren sich anzupassen
[Musik]
lassen sie noch ein bisschen uns über
ihre arbeit reden
sie sind nicht nur professorin bis heute
muss man sagen sie haben geben die
professur auf in st
und sie geben auch die vize
präsidentschaft der kobe 19 tage force
auf bleiben aber noch mitglied und über
diese kombi 1908 worden das nicht möchte
ich ein bisschen reden mit ihnen wie ich
mir das genau vorstellen muss diese
arbeit in diesem großen team mit diesen
untergruppen noch ganz unterschiedliche
fächer experten auch dabei sind
epidemiologen ärztin ökonomen sind das
nicht einfach unterschiedliche welten
die da aufeinander
frauen wie findet man sich da wie läuft
da die der disco als die diskussion ja
es sind in erster linie wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen ich glaube das
merkt man die schon selbst wenn die welt
unterschiedlich sind und zum teil
herangehensweisen unterschiedlich dass
die wissenschaft wo wir uns auch gewohnt
sind untereinander zu diskutieren
hilft natürlich uns auch auszutauschen
wenn ich ein bisschen zurückblicken kann
dass dies war eine bottom up dass eine
von unten gestartete initiative dass sie
die wissenschaftler angefangen haben im
miteinander zu diskutieren versuchen
sich sozusagen einzubringen in den
prozess
das wurde dann ende märz institution ist
institutionalisiert durch diese task
force und seit den letzten auch neun
monaten hat sich natürlich extrem viel
verändert jetzt in der pandemie auch
welche fragen überhaupt und die
task-force herankommen das hat sich
ziemlich stark geändert was ich nicht
geändert hat ist dass das war wirklich
versucht die fragen die kommen
ich komme aus dem bundesamt für
gesundheit die kommen departementes
ähneln dass die dass wir die versuche
auch von verschiedenen seiten zu
beleuchten
da werden unterschiedlichen gruppen
gearbeitet und nasen some papers oder
und stellungnahmen beispielsweise die
gruppe ökonomie stellt sich die fragen
wie wie müsste man 30 tests finanzieren
das war eins der ersten page die wir
gemacht haben
die haben beispielsweise auch die die
kosten des kontakt tracing in
verhältnissen kosten des lok tanz
berechnet und die schlussfolgerung war
kontakt verfolgen kostet nichts im
vergleich zu locken und daneben auch die
diese trajdos also diese zielkonflikte
zwischen gesundheit und wirtschaft zu
beleuchten
wir hatten aber auch eine starke
leistung auch sagen dass es diesen
konflikt so gar nicht gibt weil ich sie
richtig verstehe zwischen gesundheit und
wirtschaft sowie der oft dargestellt
wurde
ja in der ersten reihe glaubt das sicher
nicht es gab das auch in der
beispielsweise spanischen grippe in oder
am rande und der grund ist genau deshalb
weil wir die die gegenwelt ohne
maßnahmen nicht kennen weil man geht
davon aus dass oder man kann jetzt auch
anhand von daten berechnen
wir sind sozusagen dass die
einschränkungen selber eben nicht nur
leben gerettet haben sondern auch die
die wirtschaft die wirtschaftlichen
einbrüche noch minimiert ist vielleicht
das falsche wort so klein wie möglich
gehalten haben
das war ja interessant von außen zu
sehen dass dann plötzlich die ökonomen
kann bei der zweiten welle und gesagt
haben wir brauchen viele stärkere
maßnahmen einen kurzen doktor und zum
beispiel aus wirtschaftlichen genau aber
dann wurden sie ignoriert von der
politik oft auch die task force
ja also das kann man so wirklich nicht
eigentlich die die die task force hat
natürlich nicht immer das gleiche gesagt
wie der bundesrat das ist auch nicht
ihre aufgabe
ich gehe ja auch vor anderen dass man
daten zur verfügung stellt
einschätzungen macht das ganze einordnen
das epidemiologische aus klinischer als
ökonomische aus ethischer perspektive
und sozusagen entscheidungsgrundlagen
bereitstellt für den bundesrat
[Musik]
generiert ist wirklich nicht das
richtige wort wurden sehr gut gehört
auch wenn die entscheidung vielleicht
anders ausgefallen sind
das heißt die tatsache dass sie jetzt
zurücktreten aus vizepräsidentin und
daraus professorin hat nichts mit dem zu
tun was sie sind ja erst 59 jahre jungen
ich hab das hat überhaupt nichts mit dem
zu tun ich habe an der hsg habe ich am
19 märz gekündigt das war noch vor dem
lockt dann ja schon auch ein bisschen
mit corona im blick war das haben wir
einfach quasi meine meinen langen
gesehen wunsch noch etwas anderes zu
machen wenn nicht jetzt dann jetzt darum
euch das gemacht ich habe mich dann sehr
engagiert für die task force wird das
auch in zukunft tun
ich bin ab dem ersten februar auf morgen
nicht mehr institutionell und sich
angeboten ist es auch schwieriger es
gibt auch andere leute in der task force
die das genauso gut machen können wie
ich
dieses vize präsidium und ich möchte
also ich gab es diese belastung diese
task was wir machen das alles neben
unseren normalen arbeit gemacht und
dadurch ist ein wechsel ab und zu auch
in der leitung sinn für die haben ja sie
haben ja noch viele andere funktionen
und hüte auf sie sind mitglied des
bankrats das schreibt der schweizerische
nationalbank sie sitzen in verschiedenen
verwaltungsräten etwa von schindler
sie leiten das schweizerische institut
für empirische wirtschaftsforschung und
dann mit ihrem mann zusammen auch eine
plattform bot punkt ch wo sich
wirtschaftsprofessorin zu aktuellen
themen äußern können also ist es
irgendwie auch eine entscheidung ein
bisschen weniger zu machen ja einfache
frage nein ich habe danach gemerkt ich
kann nicht noch mal zehn jahren zehn
jahre 150 prozent arbeiten will das auch
nicht
lassen sie uns setzen müssen in die
zukunft blickten erstmal so kurzfristige
mittelfristige folgen dieser pandemie
was einige einige aspekte haben wir
schon gesprochen ein ganz wichtiger
aspekt scheint zu sein dass sich die
ökonomische ungleichheit das heißt die
schere zwischen arm und reich dass sich
die weiter öffnet auch in der schweiz
und das hat man schon beobachtet und wir
schauen uns kurz einen ausschnitt dann
als ein dock für der fsv laufen werde
superreiche scheinen immun zu sein gegen
die korona grenze laut der bilanz haben
die 300 reichsten während der pandemie
und 5 milliarden dazu verdient und
besitzen nun mit über 700 6 milliarden
schweizer franken so viel wie noch nicht
wenn wir das mit der letzten finanzkrise
vergleichen da was so das ist drei jahre
dauerte bis der vorjahresstand plusminus
wieder erreicht wurde
jetzt hat man ja gesehen dass die börsen
sich innerhalb von vier wochen im märz
wieder erholt haben unter spiegelt sich
auch in unserer liste wieder
und deswegen aber diesen rekord erzielt
kehrseite dieser medaille sind die
langen menschenschlangen die sich seit
beginn der pandemie
überall dort bilden wo
hilfsorganisationen es waren an
bedürftige verteilt
krise verschärft bestehen die
ungleichheiten und zeigt aber faktor ist
gesellschafter der gruppensieg geschafft
wo man schon als so niedrig sei sie
haben zum beispiel an papier und
rustikale berufliche situationen sie das
bild dann müsste ja das war ein kurzer
ausschnitt aus dem dock führen die
schere der graben zwischen arm und reich
den sie am vierten verbrauch um 20.05
auf sf1 in voller länge sehen können
frau birthler warum macht diese krise
die reichen eigentlich noch reicher ja
also ich möchte vielleicht auch wieder
ein bisschen zurückgehen
die pandemie betrifft die ärmeren
tatsächlich auf 333 stufen 4 stärken sie
werden eher krank wenn sie krank sind
steffen sie ihr frommen us anders
gesehen und dem sie verlieren ihren job
das ist ganz klar das sieht man weltweit
das die die ärmsten aller länder sind
durch die krise extrem stark getroffen
worden und zwar selbst in ländern ohne
maßnahmen also das ist daher das hängt
getaucht wenigen maßnahmen pandemie
selber gleichzeitig sind die bereiche da
muss man ein bisschen die werte die
tieren es gibt auch reiche die ein
bisschen weniger reich geworden sind das
ist nicht bei allen aber sie
profitierten teilweise natürlich von
firmen die im digital sektortrends sind
aber auch in gewissen
produktionstechnologien drin die wir in
der zukunft auch weiter brauchen werden
wir sehen verwerfungen in eigentlich
allen einkommensgruppen sieht man dass
leute jobs verloren haben einkommen
verloren haben andere die sich gibt die
genau den richtigen branchen worden
haben gewonnen also die ungleichheit ist
ist nicht nur oben und unten gewachsen
sondern es ist irgendwie als ich über
das ganze land verändert die situation
bei den beiden soll papier war natürlich
immer sehr kritisch und die haben stark
profitiert besser gesagt stadtpolitik
man hat wir haben stark profitiert davon
dass viele arbeit neben nicht im legalen
sektor wagen gerade hausangestellte das
ist ein thema das ich grundsicherung
gehen ist eines schon treffen land das
ebenso viele leute letztlich in einen
illegalen verhältnissen arbeiten
gleichzeitig ist es für die politiker
auch wahnsinnig schwierig gehen wir mit
diesen song papiers um legalisieren wir
sie unterstützen wir sehr einfach wir
müssen ganz sicher etwas du vielleicht
auch etwas zur globalen ungleichheit
eine kürzliche studie von angestellten
des nobelpreisträger gezeigt dass die
globale ungleichheit zurückgegangen ist
kinder konnten in der pandemie dass die
reichen länder mehr verloren haben aus
die armen länder
das ist möglicherweise nur ein
temporäres phänomen das wissen wir in
einem jahr so was ist es ist ein
bisschen komplizierter das bild das
einfach nur die reichen reicher die
leistung war die armen gar nicht mehr
verlieren können weil es ist nicht also
gar nicht so viel zur verfügung
aber im gewiss der armee haben viel
verloren nimmt gerade dieser partie edi
hausen in haushalten angestellt worden
die haben natürlich die lebensgrundlage
verloren und haben im gegensatz zu den
ansässigen keinen zugang zur sozialhilfe
die schweiz hat es geschafft diejenigen
die ansässig sind gut zuversicht über
die sozialhilfe über die
arbeitslosigkeit personenversicherung
kurzarbeit teilweise jetzt auch
härtefälle entscheidung haben wir das
gut geschafft aber eben nur für
diejenigen die wirklich ansässig sind
und diese und papi fallen halt da wecken
und interessant waren sich auch das als
eine geschlechter ungleichheit gab es
die frauen sind viel stärker die
verliererin dieser krise woran liegt das
das sieht man auch wieder überragenden
usa aber dass eines der ersten jahren
letzten 20 jahren wo die
arbeitslosigkeit der frauen stärker
zugenommen hat dass die der männer
in den letzten 20 jahren als ich geprägt
durch so ein female labour market dass
man gesehen hat der anteil der frauen
steigt der anteil der frauen und besser
bezahlten jobs steigt und jetzt das
erste mal wirklich ein look rückschlag
das hat im wesentlichen damit zu tun
dass die kinderbetreuung während den
während der lok dann phasen letztlich
eben doch noch beiden frauen hin und
dass sie dadurch nicht mehr voll
arbeiten konnten weniger arbeiten
konnten teilweise in betrieben werden
die ihre stelle verloren haben
die handlung beispielsweise also im
gesundheitssektor offensichtlich nicht
im detailhandel eben auch gewisse
haushalt arbeiten haben sie die stellen
verloren
[Musik]
ich meine diese krise war natürlich auch
immer die auseinandersetzung mit jung
und alt weil die älteren menschen zur
risikogruppe gehören
sie forschen ja schon länger an diesem
thema einer alternden gesellschaft wird
dass unsere haltung unsere einstellung
gegenüber älteren menschen verändern
diese krise führt das zu mehr
verständnis mehr integration oder
vielleicht gerade zum gegenteil
wieder haben sie ich glaube ich ein
bisschen befragt
es ist ziemlich schwierig zu beantworten
und ökonomische werte sowieso was dazu
kommt dass die jungen sich eben sehr
stark zurücknehmen mussten jetzt in der
krise ist das ja auch finanziell
belastet werden durch alle
sicherungssysteme die nicht nachhaltig
finanziert sind und das zusammen ich da
besteht schon eine gewisse gefahr dass
sich die jungen irgendeiner
übervorteilt fühlen deshalb ist es auch
so wichtig dass wir ideal versicherung
angehen
die probleme der versicherung bevor es
eben zu diesen diesen spannungen kommt
oder diese spannungen noch größer werden
was ist die wichtigste maßnahme als er
sich die wir noch treffen sollten
wir müssen schauen dass diejenigen leute
die länger arbeiten können länger
arbeiten dass uns gerade wenn wir
zurückblicken jetzt nur schon seit 1985
ist das dem obligatorium der zweiten
säule ist die lebenserwartung sechs
jahre gestiegen das pensionsalter ist
eigentlich immer noch am gleichen ort
gleichzeitig sehen wir aber auch da eine
ungleichheit es gibt leute die mit 65
wirklich nicht mehr weiterarbeiten
können zum teil mit 60 schon nicht mehr
und dann tritt im kindergarten gestaut
man muss man muss es so gestalten können
dass diejenigen die arbeiten können und
die sich eben noch leisten können dass
die länger arbeiten oder aber dass die
rentenkürzungen dort stärker sind wo es
weniger zu sagen sie haben auch in einem
interview gesagt dass wir nach dieser
krise in einer anderen welt leben werden
was heißt das haben sie mich erwischt
ich bin keine politikerin wir ich sehe
schon dass wir extrem viele anpassungen
schon gesehen haben die firma hat sich
angepasst die leute haben sich angepasst
wir werden wahrscheinlich viele von uns
auch uns anders aufstellen und das hat
für die ganze wirtschaft erfolgen also
die die mobilität wird zum teil anders
sein das sieht man jetzt schon die die
geschäftsreisen werden zurückgehen
aber wie genau sich die menschen
anpassen dann sind extrem schwierig zu
prognostizieren ist ja auch interessant
als ich gerade in den letzten paar
monaten extrem vielen firmengründungen
von leuten die das gefühl haben jetzt
haben sie die gelegenheit wenn ich etwas
anderes zu machen dass krisen halt so
schlimm sie sind immer noch nährboden
für neue innovationen sind
darüber möchten wir jetzt nach rehden in
der verbleibenden
vierten stunde nämlich über dieses
momentum der geschichte vielleicht auch
viele sagen ja auch angesichts der
klimakrise angesichts der
digitalisierung dass da irgendwie
künstliche intelligenz job wegnimmt
wir brauchen wenn wir in zukunft haben
wollen ein anderes wirtschaftssystem die
einen sagen wir müssen uns von der idee
des wachstums des ewigen wachstums
verabschieden angesichts begrenzter
endlicher ressourcen die anderen sagen
wir brauchen so etwas für ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen weil
irgendwann werden die roboter unsere
arbeit machen und sie können nicht alle
kreativen jobs haben wie ist denn ihre
sicht auf diese dinge so ein bisschen
visionär was die wirtschaft angeht
brauchen wir wirklich ein radikales
umdenken wenn wir daran denken wir sind
unsere gesellschaft in 40 50 jahren
aussehen wird
ich habe immer ein bisschen mühe mit dem
umdenken also wer denkt um oder wer wir
sagt dann wie man umdenken so was was
wir angehen müssen ist die ganze
klimafrage und wir haben wir haben zu
großen zehen zwei jahre stoß wirklich
ihren dass wir große probleme haben
durch die klimaveränderung und das
müssen wir irgendwie angehen aber wie
genau das den leuten vorzuschreiben für
mich immer wahnsinnig schwierig also
weshalb und wer sonst dann machen wir
sollen wissen wie es weitergeht wir
wissen dass alle nicht gesehen so viele
so viele entwicklungen nur schon letzten
20 jahren konnten wir nicht voraussehen
weshalb sollen wir dann fertig sein vor
27 jahren aus meiner sicht müssen wir
vor allem dort wirtschaftspolitische
massnahmen treffen wo wir zu viel zu
viel energie brauchen zu viele rohstoffe
weil wir dadurch quasi die nächsten
generationen schädigen das ist auch eine
klassische exponat im ökonomischen sinne
indem wir zu viel energie brauchen zu
viele rohstoffe
nehmen wir nicht berechnen reicht nicht
ein dass wir die zukünftigen
generationen schaden
da gibt es aber durchaus methoden das zu
tun dass co2 zu besteuern
die ökonomen die sich sonst über alles
strahlt und strahlten sich darüber nicht
über eine co2 steuer
ja das ist konsens wirklich querbeet von
ganz rechts bis ganz links
aber es gibt auch wirklich auch einige
minderheitenpositionen die viel weiter
gehen möchten und auch die forderung der
klimabewegung ernst nehmen nach einem
systemwechsel system change stadtklima
klimaveränderung und einer dieser dieser
denker ist der deutsche ökonom niko
paech ein sogenannter post wachstums
ökonom und erfordert eine wirtschaft
gänzlich ohne wachstum und wie das genau
gehen soll das erklärt er uns am besten
gleich selbst also post wachstums
ökonomie ist also ein zukunftsentwurf
für eine ökonomie die menschen
nachhaltig leben praktizieren sich
selbst verwirklichen lässt und so weiter
dazu zählt zunächst einmal eine kultur
der genügsamkeit
das heißt also wir müssen unser leben
entrümpeln mit verzichtet das nichts zu
tun
darauf können wir gleich noch mal kurz
eingehen ich nenne es so effizienz zum
zweiten geht es darum formen der
selbstversorgung zu reaktivieren aber
nicht wie im mittelalter oder im
neandertal oder in der höhle sondern auf
moderne weise die nutzungsdauer der
dinge zu verlängern mit denen wir uns
umgeben dinge auch gemeinschaftlich zu
nutzen aber tatsächlich auch wieder
eigene produktion zu praktizieren zum
dritten geht es um eine starke regionale
ökonomie die möglichst ohne physische
produktion in der lage ist uns eben
ökologisch zu versorgen und dann bleibt
als vierte ebene der gestaltung einer
post wachstums ökonomie immer noch eine
industrie sogar eine globalisierte weil
zurück ich sage es nochmal als
mittelalter will auch ein
wachstumskritiker nicht und der erste
schritt dorthin könnte sein unser
arbeitszeitmodell so zu verändern dass
wir vielleicht nicht mehr 40 sondern 20
stunden pro woche arbeiten weil nämlich
ein ganz wichtiger wachstumstreiber
schlicht und ergreifend ein
sozialpolitischer imperativ ist nämlich
trotz eben des arbeits sparenden
technischen fortschritts
vollbeschäftigung
zu haben wenn wir aber an der 40 stunden
woche kleben dann ist es klar dass bei
zunehmendem technischen fortschritt die
wirtschaft immer weiter wachsen muss
sonst gibt es eine revolution einsatz
noch wenn wir also die arbeitszeit um
verteilen und die wöchentliche
arbeitszeit verkürzen können wir mit
einer kleineren ökonomische leben müssen
dann die freigestellten zeiteinheiten
also 20 stunden als mark freizeit
betrachtet hernehmen um ein kleiner
gewordenes geld einkommen zu ergänzen
durch diese subsistenz maßnahmen die ich
gerade schon aufgeführt hatten
wow 20 stunden woche mehr genügsamkeit
klingt doch verlockend ja nur wie kommen
wir dorthin
ich mag vielleicht nach noch mal zurück
gehen wir haben die einen großen teil
des fortschrittes des
wirtschaftswachstums in letzten 100
jahren tatsächlich in eine verkürzung
der arbeitszeit gesteckt und wenn ihr
heute sehen arbeiten die reichen länder
weniger aus die armen also es ist
tatsächlich was herr pages verlangt hat
machen wir bereits bis zu einem gewissen
grad ich würde ja dafür sprechen dass es
realisiert
die frage ist wie kommen wir da hin
verbieten hier den leuten mehr als 20
stunden zu arbeiten oder ist das
schlussendlich ein fachmann das resultat
des tests der nächsten jahre dass sich
die produktion ändert dass wir uns dass
wir anders leben und wir leben ja in
einer demokratie wie können hat die
wirtschaft selbst mitgestalten wie
können die gesellschaft selber
mitgestalten
eine beschränkung der arbeitszeit durch
mich jetzt nicht so demokratisch aus sie
wird natürlich demokratisch bestimmt das
wird aber nicht das wirtschaftswachstum
passe einfach nicht die wirtschaft per
sehen warum kennt aber würden sie sagen
das ist überhaupt erstrebenswert da
hinzukommen würden sie sagen nein besser
nicht wirtschaftswachstum sollten wir
nicht antasten ja wo sie mit man muss
sich fragen woher kommt
wirtschaftswachstum und das ist auch ein
mechanisches bildet das herr pächter hat
so wie wenn da jemand irgendwie dreht
und diese schraube kann dann einfach
abgestellt wird
per knopfdruck wirtschafts wachstum
entsteht vor allem eben durch neue ideen
durch innovation
wir sehen uns jetzt in der krise klar
ich kam so viele deren gründung gegeben
weil leute ist eine idee haben wir
machen mit dieser veränderten welt
umgehen kann und weil die das wachstum
vor allem eben durch neue ideen kommt
müsste man die neuen ideen abstellen das
ist vollkommen nicht und so dafür dass
man kann nur sagen ist kein wachstum
geben wenn es gute ideen ging das muss
darf kein zwang geben dazu also der
schweizer ökonom mathias binswanger hat
ja ein buch geschrieben mit diesem titel
wachstumszwang also es ist ja irgendwie
so als müssten wir wachsen also wer
zwingt sie zum wachsen wir zwingt uns zu
wachsen
also wir haben keine regierung die uns
zu den globalen wettbewerb vielleicht ja
das ist ein wettbewerb für die firma
halt mit tun wollen müssen offenbar nach
mathias binswanger ob wir haben nicht
einfach so ein einfaches weltbild wo
jemand das wachstum jetzt zwingen kann
oder nicht wir können dich
rahmenbedingungen schaffen dass das
wachstum tatsächlich kleiner wird indem
wir einfach alles verbieten oder den
menschen die freiräume einschränken
die freiräume ist schon eines der der
brutstätten sozusagen für den ideen für
wachstum letztlich habe sie würden ja
sagen mit also wenn wir die zukünftigen
generationen und die natur anschauen da
haben wir gut begründen die sozusagen zu
verzichten und einzuschränken oder
irgendwie zu besteuern also ich bin ich
glaube die einschränkung diese so
genannten negativen externen dass wir
die zukünftige generation schädigen
das müssen machen das heißt aber nicht
dass der staat von außen sozusagen uns
zwingen
das ist dann die frage ist ob das in
einem demokratischen prozess durch geht
das ist ja ein bisschen auch die
position der klima jugend die sagt ja
dass das dass ich sage ich nichts für
die demokraten sich der mann so
technokratisch beschließen damit schon
sehr skeptisch letztlich
verlegt das nicht wir müssen denn wir
müssen erklären können weshalb es
einschränkungen braucht neben co2
besteuerung den einschränkungen die die
unser leben weitere ich freiheitlich
gehen auch zu verfolgen und dann
möglicherweise geht das wachstum zurück
also das wachstum geht ja schon zurück
die letzten 20 jahren hat es wachstum
weltweit deutlich tiefer aus vorherigen
industrie nationen ganz bestimmt
deutlich tiefer es gibt einige ökonomen
die davon ausgehen dass die wachs das
wachstum noch kleiner wird weil wir alle
älter werden weil wir eben grenzen
kommen
aber das ist das sind dann die grenzen
die uns die das wachstum einschränken
und nicht unbedingt eben diese wachstums
knopf den man abdrehen kann wenn ich sie
schon mal hier habe der sternstunde
philosophie interessiere mich natürlich
auch es gibt also auf solche ideen dass
man das bruttoinlandproduktes bip
irgendwie als indikator für eine
florierende wirtschaft dass man das
vielleicht mal ein bisschen beiseite
schieben sollte und andere indikatoren
nehmen sollte etwa glück also wie in
bhutan zb das spricht man von einem
bruttonationalglück also dass das ziel
der wirtschaft nicht noch mehr profit
noch mehr gewinnen ist sondern ein gutes
leben dass wir uns selbst entfalten
können.die dass etwa der indische ökonom
und philosoph friedensnobelpreisträger
matthias n gesagt hat also die chance
uns zu entfalten
das muss es doch sein und nicht die
reine profitmaximierung was halten sie
von solchen ideen
es ist besser ein mannes geführt für den
einzelnen ist die das gute leben immer
mehr auf geld sonst würden wir 100
prozent also würden wir 24 stunden am
tag und 16 stunden am tag arbeiten dann
hätten wir noch viel mehr geld
wir bewegen uns immer in einem
spannungsfeld zwischen wie viel verdiene
ich und was mache ich damit was mache
ich mit meiner freizeit ist immer eine
abwägung zwischen verschiedenen sachen
und das ist wahrscheinlich auch der
grund weshalb man dieses brutto glücks
produkt das auch immer heisst anschauen
es gibt ja auch viele andere indikatoren
hin
gleiche richtung gehen die in dem weg
von von den zahlen
die produktion gehen gemeinwohl ökonomie
jetzt vielleicht zu den zahlen die die
der zusammenhang die korrelation
zwischen diesen glücks indikatoren und
den einfachen zahlen des
bruttosozialprodukts bruttoinlandprodukt
die zeit ist sehr stark an sulander
länder die relativ reis sind haben eine
höhere lebenserwartung eine höhere
schulbildung eine bessere partizipation
den mädchen besseren umweltschutz muss
man jetzt auch noch sagen dann die das
wachstum in den letzten 50 jahren hat
uns dazu braucht das die umweltschutz
sie viele umweltverschmutzung
zurückgegangen sind in reichen ländern
und das sind auch die ihn das sind auch
die impuls die in diesen glücks
indikatoren oder diesen social welfare
indikatoren drin sind dass das ist
ziemlich stark korreliert ist natürlich
über die zeit ist es interessant zu
sehen wie sich so ein gutes produkt
sozusagen weiterentwickelt jetzt ich bin
vielleicht etwas pragmatischer etwas
mehr ein boot wenn ich wenn ich das
bruttoinlandprodukt verwenden wählen und
vielleicht wirtschaftspolitik zu
betreiben und solche zahl dann dann
brauche ich zahlen die verlässlich sind
die man relativ häufig erheben kann
wir haben jetzt während der krise
gesehen dass selbst dieses dieses
nüchterne bruttoinlandprodukt nicht
waren sie nie gut war um die krise nach
zu verfolgen weil das nur alle drei
monate überhaupt behoben werden kann und
eine der innovation der krisen war dass
viele universitäre institutionen und
aber auch die bundes behörden angefangen
haben versuchen nach indikatoren zu
suchen die das wirtschaftsleben näher
und werden schneller abbilden
beispielsweise energiekonsum mobilitäts
den anmeldungen für kurzarbeit viele
solche indikatoren die die es eben
braucht um wird auf politik zu machen
interessant das heißt so eine krise
könnte auch dazu führen dass man sich
auf andere indikatoren stützen wir die
auch in zukunft weil sie einfach
schneller sind und besser messen was
passiert als das bip
das wird ganz sicher
war dieser indikatoren sind so viel
schneller verfügbar teilweise auch
belastbar
um wirklich zu sehen wie entwicklung wir
uns wenn sie können schon alle zwei tage
die leute fragen ob sie glücklich sind
oder nicht aber jetzt während der
pandemie wäre das wahrscheinlich nicht
unbedingt denn gut dass gutes maß
gewesen um zu sehen wie geht es uns
vielleicht auch mal zurück zum
materiellen dass wir haben oft das
gefühl dass wachstum vor allem an
materielle sagst du bist wer hört schon
die letzten jahre nicht mehr letzten
jahrzehnte natürlichen teil ist wir
haben mehr wohnraum vielleicht auch mehr
mobilität aber ein großer teil ist
qualität ich qualitativ haben wir
bessere produkte also die ganzen die
ganzen technologien sind besser geworden
auf die uns verlassen
wir haben ich habe ein kilo mäßig
deutlich weniger computer heute aus ich
noch vor 30 jahren hatte aber mit einer
10.000 fache leistung das ist auch
wachstum materiell ist es aber kein
wachstum muss ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir wachstum immer nur von der
materiellen seite her sehen dass selbst
diese zonen die sich nicht einfach mehr
stoff auf dem tisch so vielleicht
besseres ab das nehme ich gerne mit und
vielleicht auch die idee dass weniger in
bestimmten bereichen doch mehr sein kann
sie machen das jetzt vor in dem sie sehr
selbstbewusst auf bestimmte jobs wieder
abgeben wo sich andere daran geklammert
hatten wir sind leider schon am ende
dieser stunde ich habe sehr viel gelernt
vielen herzlichen dank monika bütler
hätte dank ihnen ja und danke ihnen fürs
mitdenken nächsten sonntag fallen mir 50
jahre frauenstimmrecht in der schweiz
barbara bleisch empfängt eine exzellente
runde von wissenschaftlerinnen und fragt
wer entscheidet eigentlich heute wer in
einer demokratie mitreden darf und werde
und jetzt gleich widmen wir uns eine
ikone der befreiung josephine baker
wurde von der tänzerin in bananen hoc
zur politischen figur ein film über
ihren aufstieg aus armut und
unterdrückung hin zum superstar
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]